time to kibitz the war zone open five
seconds remaining until kickoff
there are 229 people playing 1785
average rating you could enter as the
term is going on so there's gonna be a
little chart that pops up here soon
enough here's the chart let's go to a
game and jump in right now whoa I think
we're gonna be seeing a lot of this guy
yes we are he already won let's jump in
another one pot pie is the top game
against Red May 2200 versus 1934 these
are 2-minute games Sicilian alipin okay
space advantage okay this is a tough
adjustment by the way I've played so
many one-minute games that when I jump
into a two-minute one those tricks that
I would normally go for don't really
work they don't work do they so this is
it started out Sicilian alla pin and now
we have a French structure so there was
a time disadvantage from the beginning
okay this is a war zone so the times are
adjusted according to rating the F file
will be made use of Bishop d3 best spot
for that Bishop Castle the rook is
excited about this and now White has
absolutely no worry about d4 what the
implications of this is that white
cannot be pressing forward more freely
with E 4 so I'm assuming that we'd see
something like that soon enough this
bishop has seen better days and well I
guess this could potentially be a target
but it seems just a long way off it's a
convenient move to just play rook c1 to
watch over and sure enough we do have
this e 4 move the knight is eyeing f4 I
don't know how much of an inconvenience
that is maybe we could have Queen d2 to
watch over it and I think something is
straightforward as doubling on the F
file and white is going to be doing very
well
rip b1 b5 no
purposeful there would be one move is if
we're seeing b5 unless White's intention
is to crack at it yet again with a four
so that could have been an idea as well
Queen to d2 less than a minute for Team
white Queen to d2 watches over f4 at any
moment we could just have this takes and
the bishop is unleashed on this diagonal
okay I guess prepping b4 time
disadvantages may be getting a bit it's
a bit of an issue is it not
okay so white is going in a much
different direction this move is saying
maybe double on the b file unless the
rook is planning on swinging over to f2
can't say for certain
h4 looking to shoo this night away and
it is shoot away age six is going to be
incredibly weakened here comes f6
there's going to be a knight that wants
to get right here h6 g6 Knight h2g for
f6 bad news for black h2g for f6 big
trouble here we go
weakened squares weakened squares is
this Knight gonna be able to get here
successfully I don't think that there's
going to be a problem with that or is
there if Bishop takes take with the pond
that way the knight could play here to
defend if pawn push the Queens are in
tension with one another I think ideally
black would like to get the Queens off
the board that way they're not going to
get made on g7 at least however this
pawn is still a giant thorn and now
Knight f6 I guess black is planning to
run in this direction but it's dropping
h7 so this right here
big trouble the queen is looking for g7
and the knight says not so fast 17
seconds for white we'll see right after
this game what the standings are 17
minutes oh yeah 17 seconds - 47 seconds
Queens are in tension with one another
g4 you kicked this night away the Queen
wants to get to f6 and then made on g7
will it happen
the Queen is a step away
actually the knight is here to watch
over this square but the rook can remove
the knight Oh
there's not going to be a good solution
and the time is now balancing out here
14 seconds to 22 seconds not a good
solution Queen takes rook Queen takes
Knight you name it this is going to be
TKO 12 seconds is plenty of time is it
not f7 is hit the cleanest hit the King
is going to be hit Queen takes pawn Oh
kitchen sink land 10 seconds is more
than enough time matin - Queen takes
pawn and then Queen here how the king is
running a little bit that is game over
let me jump out and see how the
standings are who is winning the leaders
whoa somebody has 20 a couple people
have 20 let's see a top game this is
somebody who has 20 somebody who's 1466
what 1466 vs. a 1909 kidding me that's
crazy town oh well actually this guy is
way down material he is going to be
dropping back I would assume we could
also have what else can we have here we
could have resignation one day or we
could experience we actually had here's
something you can't see white actually
offered a draw white offered a draw was
like please just accept this draw you
know you want to draw and black is like
no you will have no job you will suffer
I will beat you black is up on the clock
and the position okay we're just having
the clock being milk actually it's not
exciting and if it's not exciting I'm
done viewing it okay these two guys here
mule train we got a 20 to 34 versus a
2147 these guys are battling it out we
have some action here so we're gonna go
where there is
action none of that no no fried stuff
avoid the Nonna fries is the plan
basically avoid the clock tickers and
the positions that we know the result -
do we know the results of this one
however okay D file is well not yet
completely opened I was my first thought
we're just gonna have takes right there
but now not the case alright so c5 jump
a night into b6
you know one of these this is one of
these positions where it might seem
appealing to maybe cement tonight on b6
but it could find itself out of play
dark square bishop have been exchanges
their way to exploit this King position
I'm not really seeing that happen this
night is certainly a long way off from
eyeing these two squares but now okay
this square is maybe a big issue b5
however is a nice shot this knife of the
moment can't make use of its uh of the
c3 square but maybe you can it can get
to this C 4 square forks forks calling
out Forks c3 the knight is hitting the
house a 2d 5d 1 where is the technique
it could still be a bit tricky this is
the leader with 26 points
he is the pack leader right there I
think I'll check the leaders right after
this let's see how this is gonna finish
up still requiring some technique here
keep more pieces on the board
don't take what the rook take with the
pond this is more exciting than the
other game that was completely beat
watch that guy all be inferred he'll
somehow he maybe somehow managed to win
Queenie to guard against these checks
okay no the Queen f1 what's the
follow-up though not really seeing it
okay soon enough Knight d5 still some
hope for white or not or not okay
because after king h2 rook f2 hitting
the Queen and g2 lights out lights out
Queen takes g2 game over just ready say
back to tournament
I could say that I could say that back
back to tournament but I'm not playing
this one he's still up there 38 38 30 28
another game let's try this guy he's a
new one slipknot 1878 1878 vs. 2013 rook
and pawn end game black is doing better
black might be chipping away at this
this guy who has 30 points right here
King activity well it's still a little
tactical here still very tactical what
about rook here uh-oh black could be
getting mated oh oh we could have a
perpetual check maybe Oh looking for me
look rook f8 is a main threat oh boy oh
it's defended the king could sneak away
in this direction now the king is active
black is gonna win this
unless time is going to be an issue the
king is not going to be getting made it
he's just improving his position as
these checks are being thrown and he's
just inching closer and will soon be
contributing to taking away squares from
this King there's always a perpetual
check but black could be getting more
than that however white is still being a
bug looking to grab this pawn I think
coming calmly all the way back to defend
taking the pig out for that second rank
is probably the cleanest way to do
things okay 16 seconds for black three
pawns three pawns plus exchange rooks go
from tactical to completely technical
position mate threat rook B to defend
the pawn push the pawn push these pawns
you name it oh that's gonna be game over
seven seconds black should be able to do
this right move the King here push the
pawn moving fast enough it seems five
point six less than five getting a rook
what why did it get a rook oh that's me
it doesn't matter
back to tournament
at the leaders we're the pack leader is
38 29 28 let's grab another top game one
of the top games top PI again 2200
versus 1924 okay this one is just
starting out I have to see what the
beginning of the game was okay we had a
like a Smith more gambit declined
dark-squared bishop will be coming off
soon f3 is okay could the queen really
make you said this diagonal maybe Queen
check grab this pawn okay it's not
played right here is that's a threat of
maybe winning a piece but the rook is
there in time to defend one of the minor
pieces now there's possibilities for a
discovered check against the Queen mmm
tricky knight Knight c5 grab this Bishop
and this position is destroyed but it's
not without allowing the Queen to grab
on a - okay calmly coming back a more
positional approach you could grab this
pawn right here okay black is up upon
are there any sneaky tricks
okay just getting off of this diagonal a
good prophylactic move to make good
prophylactic move King takes Knight f4
as a possibility okay the rooks are
coming off the queen is getting this
pawn but the Queen is maybe getting this
one the rook is hit however hmm rook d5
prevent the Queen check I think I'm
liking black better here
rook d5 the Queen starts pressure on b2
the knight could come back to f6 and
what else okay rook b5 everything seems
to be defended well on the black side
with rook b5 Knight f6 the King is
tucked in very nicely okay the rook is
having thoughts of just getting to a1
but are we gonna have Queen takes b7
white getting a pawn back but black
having a more active rook rook b4 might
be a move keep the Queens on the board
or not okay we're not
having Queen trade the Queen is still
very active I like to rugby 5 getting at
this point b2 and then looking to take
on c3 hitting the rook about even on
time white trying to come up with
something here it's difficult to get
these pawns rolling rook a to seems very
active but it would run into Bishop d5
skewers so the knight is kicked away the
King now has a flight Square two reasons
to want to do g3 basically get out of
there Knight and flight square for a
king
balanced with time 45 seconds each Queen
d2 I guess is just protecting all base
points this pawn is pinned getting out
of the pin right away good idea how to
get this C pawn rolling he is past a
slight time advantage the Queen is
eyeing Age 3 but I don't know even if
she's there just backing up one the
Queen is there to watch over each - okay
this is available right now but there is
a check the king is going back soon
no he's now why did he go there I don't
understand that is that is suicidal
isn't it when you go to h6 like that
okay we're gonna have this aren't we
okay now White has a time advantage of
material advantage things are looking
good for Team white and not so good for
team black who is down time and position
the Queen's are coming off and I'll
watch the end of this almost a hundred
percent certain who's gonna win White's
gonna win this ninety nine and a half
times out of a hundred and they did not
make me a liar okay who is up there 66
54-51 another top game let's see that
leader what is he eating what is this
guy eating I'm gonna flip the board I
want to see things from him from his
perspective
let's see let us see then let us see
what this guy is eating he's eating more
than granola bars
this Knight would love to get to d4 or
sack himself h3 nowhere what is that I
have to learn that move right there just
sac the piece instead of posting it on a
nice square I have to learn that one Oh
keep in mind I don't know I was just
ready to say well why was down material
that's not the case I lied Black has two
pawns for the piece and okay only later
makes use of D for a strong Knight
difficult to get rid of you get rid of
the knight and now you have to deal with
the past D pun which might not be so bad
take the knight and then play bishop
here have the bishop be a block hater
and get these pawns rolling in some way
or maybe even better this is a nice
diagonal for that Bishop maintaining one
pawn here in the center bishop to this
square giving a check less than a minute
for white against the tournament leader
with 127 remaining this guy's flying
these two pawns are past this pond is
blockaded this rook is getting active
these rooks are sneaking in white is
neutralizing this rook that was cutting
off the King I really have no idea how
this gonna tom push bishop check might
be an idea this King is running short on
squares has no legal moves at the moment
looking for checks is black I think with
rook to h3 very active pieces for black
the rooks functioning both laterally and
along these files a lot of slot of
ground being covered the King is now
just trying to run away and I think he
is able to do that successfully King
here time situation less than a minute
for black now who has been rattling off
these moves in a way that is very
difficult to keep up with
okay so trying to dislodge that bishop
from its nice post it's reasonable and
white says no I will stay right here you
will not push me around with b5 King
improvement this is purposeful now we
have g5g for these pawns inch closer and
this Knight
well really just black does not like to
have to deal with any passed pawns
forget about the knight not liking them
no pieces like to have to stop a passed
pawn this night is now boxed out by that
dark square bishop the King is a
fighting piece there is no serious pun
threat here that white has okay I mean
like these this guy's past he can't get
working though what does he do
so King up my rook is hit the knight is
pinned time situation less than 13 Oh
giving this up is this is this a savable
position this pawn is passed
can the King stop these two and this
pawn get marching oh this pawn is passed
as well oh this is gonna be a win for
the leader the pack leader is not
leaving his post that's game over
we'd have to watch anymore he won you're
just gonna have to believe me good
enough to believe me
take my word for it he is going to win
that one once again that is like a
ninety-nine out of a hundred type of
game but this guy has something to say
about this tournament twenty to thirty
five player I'm looking from this guy's
perspective I want to know the tricks of
the trade here so material is balanced
looking for mate right here that night
runs away there was not night h4 to
defend against g2 Queen is hit the night
is intolerable the night is taken this
Knight is constrained to g2 now we have
a role reversal this Knight wants to be
able to move but when you ask him where
you gonna move he doesn't he kind of
just looks at you silly c3 shuts down
this Bishop on the diagonal now Khan
takes bishop was threatened the bishop
gets out of the way and is hitting at d3
for its third time rook Bishop Queen
soon enough a fourth is going to be
hitting
here and things become very difficult
not to mention that efore is available
breaking at everything now looking good
for Team white who is really playing on
three ranks right here ranks one two and
three versus five ranks for black II
four and I think we can maybe even flip
the switch on this one and go elsewhere
this is a successful pawn break how do
you deal with that
you really don't you just sidestep the
pawn takes Queen and this Bishop is uh
out of here he's out of here or like
that that's actually cleaner that is
much cleaner and you know what time
issue mmm do I really have to watch this
one any further this mister pawns guy I
think we can say is going to win you're
just gonna have to believe me
once again black is gonna win that one
ninety-nine out of a hundred times this
guy is still around leaders 104 what is
this guy eating I keep saying it I just
what I want to know what kind of granola
bars this guy chewing on here okay II
five is the one break I guess to get in
or this pawn advanced to induced
weaknesses on f5 mmm b5 b4 to kick this
night around but I think it would be a
case of kicking the night to a favorable
square he wants to go here anyhow or
maybe he doesn't maybe he didn't his
pawn is dead he's a dead duck right here
on CT oh okay
so white is up upon and this night is
gonna find a nice home on d5 I don't
think it would would have been better to
maintain that tension cuz now it just
helps this rook out unless there's
tactical shot like we're just seeing
exploiting this pin something I didn't
see oh and there we go with the knight
you could also grab this Knight this is
probably close to game over again are we
gonna have resignation Bishop takes pawn
this is just the mopping up phase of the
game I guess we'll watch a little bit
more of it pawn push you name it we're
gonna have a tsunami of pawns support
this Bishop he's not going anywhere
push push push no issue with time
no issue with position I think this is
once more one of these ninety-nine out
of a hundred games black will win is it
not
what's the verdict give me some pointers
in the twitch chat do I abandon these
games that are completely dead or do I
stick around and watch paint dry paint
dry mode or switch that or flip the
switch quickly in the twitch chat next
somebody said next I agree I agree and
if you want to blame me for clicking on
next it was della Khan in the tricky
Knight who said so so blame them get on
their case in the meantime who is
challenging for first Popeye is up there
the pack leader no pressure no pressure
flip let's see what the pie has going on
here Knight g6
ok this is very awkward now the Queen
could not only get hit but this door has
been slammed on the bishop the bishop is
not seeing in this diagonal just yet but
if it did go there it's just biting on a
rock in the meantime ok black has a
space advantage the FF file has been
peeled open d4 become efore becomes very
important to control Knight d2 to e4 is
there just in time the bishop probably
does well to just sit on its home square
the knight takes up a nice residence
here now what we could see if we have
too many exchanges and that's not what I
was expecting I thought Bishop takes
would have been better but we're not
having that pawn push things are getting
very violent f5 is a threat hitting with
a fork is there gonna be a dent is the 6
is the 6 max going to put a dent in the
pack leader
okay Queen here to control this g5
advance and not to mention facilitating
this prawn advance okay so that is that
is pretty interesting it also frees up
that d4 square for the knight and the
knight can maybe be making use of e to
this prawn seems like it's a little bit
vulnerable to just being captured okay
the night is a very tricky piece however
and keep in mind that if Knight takes
Knight pawn takes would be a check so
very tricky now pawn takes with the
check maybe something that white
overlooked or did they now we have
structural changes wherever you look
along with the fourth the exchange is
there pawn push hard push there's
possibilities for a bishop check this
pond cannot be underestimated as well
less than a minute for black rook is now
very active six d3 the pawns are
advancing on both sides both having just
a couple squares away from oh wait a
second there was a missed opportunity
Queen check on see forward black just
missed it right there mates right on g7
dark square weaknesses pawn push
potential for Connie 700 is there a way
to save this I think there is King g1
the rook could give a check the bishop
or Brooke can block I think he'd be
better to block with the bishop or would
it pawn push oh it's whit's check this
is me know it's not gonna be major
skeptic there's at least perpetual the
Queen could go back and forth is this
gonna be made bishop check having to
give it back up the King is a what a
walk
King h4 can you get that King Queen
takes rook uh-oh you can promote this
King is running way out of squares 22
seconds remaining for black checker ooh
ski on g3 uh-oh uh-oh this is me no it's
not no it's not
two queens Ted Oh 19 seconds the king is
a fighting piece whoa
what happened there bishop has to block
and now the rook is dead
oh what a comeback the Queen could take
the pawn ten seconds remaining or a mate
until what a comeback oh man Oh black
resigns no excuse me white resigns what
a comeback in that one oh man leaders
leaders how much time less than five
minutes remaining pawns is up there
let's track down
another one another one pawns what is
this guy what is this guy up to right
here pawns is on the black side here
what a battle that one was okay the
knight is there just in time to guard h7
there was Bishop takes Knight threat and
then Bishop takes h7 oh man that was
exciting stuff right there g6 okay g6 is
just preventing any nonsense right there
white is looking for a minority attack
with b4 b5 black is preventing that
right away there is no a for both Queen
and Knight are there to watch over
otherwise that might have been a good
idea Knight is playing here so that
Bishop f5 is they're exchanging off
classic bad for good bishop or Knight
there okay trying to pick up the knight
for Bishop exchange what a big
transition this game is from last game I
don't know that we're really gonna see
another one that was as crazy as that
one with both both sides just really
pushing their pawns right at their
opponent those are those pawns were so
close to cleaning for white in that game
okay anyhow minor piece are the minority
attack is successful now there's a
problem on c6 less than a minute for the
leader here pawns who's weighing in at
20 to 35 and has 156 points in this
tournament so far a tournament that is
winding down very quickly about how much
time left three minutes remaining until
we have a leader who is it gonna be we
are gonna see it's not gonna be me this
is more laid back though it's more laid
back much less stressful we could see a
fork happening very soon if takes Bishop
takes there would be a fork on those
rooks and now we have a skewer forks and
skewers everywhere and after the smoke
clears I believe black stands better
Queen moves Bishop takes drop Queen
takes pawn black is up upon this is not
looking good for Team white
in this position or on the clock well
it's pretty even on the clock what do
you do here white needs to keep a close
eye on the sea pond number-one priority
don't let this pond do anything exciting
so rook is here the king is okay he has
a flight Square there might however be a
queen check followed by a rook here and
there's make threats on g8 or excuse me
f8 serious threat I think the rook needs
to give a check and I think um really we
could just have pawn push that's saving
right and now the Queen is there to
watch over FA that's sneaky oh this is
all so sneaky that was made g3 was not
played that hurts game over right there
who are the leaders who are the leaders
176 162 130 these two guys are
neck-and-neck let's try this guy is he
ready to win what is f 3 is f3 and mouse
leper maybe not okay
let's flip the board on this one this
one could turn out to be a massacre very
quickly 1590 rated vs. 2147 this guy's
beating people up left and right oh man
oh man h3 what's the intention of this
advance there's actually two reasons
behind age 4 age 3 to be a thorn in the
white side and also clear the way for
Knight h5 stuff if you could imagine
this diagonal being controlled by a
bishop or a queen then there's
possibilities for like a knight h5 to g3
type of thing sort of like a fishing
pole
sort of thing that goes on with that g3
square we're not seeing anything except
oh well game drawn mutual agreement to
the tournament end I don't know what
that was about a draw
what kind of tactic was that well what
just went on right there what is this
guy this is the pack leader there's only
40 seconds left if he's not
able to win within those 40 seconds
that's going to be it and it's not
looking like it's gonna finish 19
seconds remaining no time remaining this
one is just going to be called oh is
that gonna be it the Knights in a pin it
doesn't really matter just to have the
clock tick on this one nothing exciting
here turning over it says it's completed
this one's just gonna be called any
second who are the leaders who is going
to be awarded the winner complete its
official pawns the guy who's rated 20 to
35 was the winner with the score of 176
in second 162 159 these guys right here
get to enjoy the confetti good games all